in this presentation we're going to
learn how to graph trig functions
without having to kind of graph point by
point and and hopefully after this
presentation you can also look at a trig
function and be able to figure out the
back droll analytic definition of the
function as well so let's start let's
say f of X let me share my I'm using all
the right tools so let's say that f of X
is equal to let's say it equals two sine
of let's say 1/2 X so when we look at
this a couple interesting things here
how is this different than just a
regular sine function well here we have
two we multiplying two the whole
function by two and also the coefficient
on the X term is 1/2 and if you've seen
some of the videos I've made you'll know
that this term affects the amplitude and
this term affects the the period or the
inverse of the period which is the
frequency either way it depends whether
you talk about 1 or 1 or the inverse of
the other one so let's start with the
amplitude this 2 tells us that the
amplitude of this function is going to
be 2 because if it was just a one there
the amplitude would be 1 so it's going
to be 2 times that so let's let's draw a
little dotted line up here at y equals
supposed to be y equals 2 and then
another dotted line at y equals negative
2 y equals negative 2
and now we have to figure out so we know
this is the amplitude we know that the
function is going to somehow oscillate
between these two points but we have to
figure out how fast is it going to
oscillate between the two points or
what's its period and I'll give you a
little formula here that the graph or
the function is equal to the amplitude
times let's say sine but it would also
work with the cosine the amplitude of
the function times sine of
two pi divided by the period of the
function times X now it might not this
right here is a P so it might not be
completely obvious where this comes from
what I want you to do is maybe after
this video or maybe in future videos
we'll experiment when we see what
happens when we change this coefficient
of the X term and I think it'll start to
make sense to you why this equation
holds but let's just take this as kind
of an act of faith right now that 2pi
divided by the period is the coefficient
on X so if we say that 2pi divided by
the period 2pi divided by the period is
equal to the coefficient which is 1/2 I
know this is extremely messy and this is
separate from this so 2pi divided by the
period is equal to 1/2 or we could say
1/2 the period is equal to 2pi or the
period is equal to 4pi so we know the
amplitude is equal to 2 and the period
is equal to 4pi and once again how did
we figure out that the period is equal
to 4pi we use this formula 2pi divided
by the period is the coefficient on the
x-term so we set 2pi divided by the
period equal to 1/2 and then we solve
that the period is 4pi so where do we
start well what happen is sine what is f
of zero what is f of zero here well when
x is equal to 0 this whole term is zero
so what's sine of zero sine of zero is
zero if you remember you I guess you
could use a calculator but that's
something you should remember or you
could relook at the unit circle to
remind yourself sine of 0 is 0 and then
0 times 2 is 0 so f of 0 is 0 all right
we'll do it right there and we know that
it has a period of 4 pi that means that
the function is going to repeat after 4
pi so if we go out it should repeat back
out here at 4 pi and now we can just
kind of draw the function and and this
will take a little bit of practice but
actually I'm gonna draw it then we can
explore a little bit more as well so the
function is going to
like this oh boy this is more difficult
than I thought and then it will keep
going in this direction as well and
notice the period here you could draw it
from you can do it from well you can do
it from here to here this this distance
is 4pi that's how long it takes for the
function to repeat or to go through one
cycle or you could also if you want you
could measure this this distance to the
did this distance this would also be 4
pi and that's the period of the function
and then of course the amplitude of the
function which is this right here is 2
here's the amplitude and then the period
of 4pi we figured out from this equation
another way we could have thought about
it let's say let's say that let me erase
some of the stuff let's say I didn't
have this stuff right here let's say I
didn't know I didn't know what the
function was and let me get rid of all
of this stuff right and all I saw was
this graph and I asked I would have and
I asked you to figure it go the other
way using this graph try to figure out
what the function is then we would you
would just see well how long does it
take for the function to repeat well it
takes 4 pi radians for the function to
repeat so you'd be able to just visually
realize that the period of this function
is 4 pi and then you would say well
what's the amplitude the amplitude is
easy you would just see how high it goes
up or down and it goes up too right you
don't you don't when you do the
amplitude you don't do the whole swing
you just do how much it swings in the
positive or negative direction so it's
the amplitude is 2 so the I'm using the
wrong color the the period is 4pi
amplitude is 2 and then your question
would be well this is an oscillating
this is a periodic function is it a sine
or is it a cosine function well cosine
function if assuming we're not doing any
shifting and in a future model module I
will shift along the x-axis but assuming
we're not doing any shifting cosine of 0
is one right and sine of zero is zero
and what's this function at zero well
it's zero right so this is going to be a
sine function so we would use this
formula here f of X is equal to the
amplitude times the sine of two pi
divided by the period times X so we
would know that the function is f of X
is equal to the amplitude times sine of
2 pi over the period 4 pi X and of
course these cancel out and then this
cancels that becomes and this becomes 2
sine of 1/2 X I know this is a little
difficult to read my apologies and I'll
ask you a question what would this
function look like f of X equals 2
cosine of 1/2 X well it's going to look
the same elite but we're going to start
at a different point cosine what's
cosine of 0 when X is equal to 0 this
whole term is equal to 0 cosine of 0 we
learned before is 1 so f of 0 is equal
to 2 let me write that F of 0 is equal
to 2 so f of 0 let me do this in a
different color and let me draw the
cosine function different color we would
start here f of 0 is equal to but
everything else is the same the
amplitude is the same and the period is
the same so now it's going to look like
this I hope it'll mess this up this is
difficult so now the function is going
to look like this
and you're going to go down here and
you're gonna rise up again
in here and on this side you're gonna do
the same thing and keep going so notice
the cosine and the sine functions look
awfully similar and there and the way to
differentiate them is what they do well
what they do in general but where they
the easiest way is what happens when you
you input a 0 into the function what
happens at the y-axis or when X is equal
to 0 or when the the angle that you
input into it is equal to 0 unless we're
doing shifting and don't worry about
shifting for now I'll do that in future
modules sine of 0 is 0
while quois cosine of 0 would be 1 and
since we're multiplying it times this
factor right here times this number
right here it the 1 becomes a 2 and so
this is the graph of cosine of X this is
the graph of sine of X and this is a
little bit of a preview for shifting
notice that the pink graph or cosine of
X is very similar to the green graph and
it's just shifted
it's just shifted this way by well in
this case it's shifted by PI right and
this actually has something to do with
the period of the coefficient in general
cosine of X is actually sine of X
shifted to the left by by PI over 2 but
I don't want to confuse you too much
that's all the time I have for this
video I will now do another video with a
couple of more examples like this